okay we are taking calls at 6 1 7 830
4750 that's always the number to call
when we take phone calls we will take
our next caller from the 913 area code
caller what's your name and where you
calling from oh hello David my name is
andrew and i'm originally from casey
with right now I'm living in that okay
great what's on your mind um oh well um
I get a little issue I wanted to ask you
about okay i know i think i speak for a
lot of your fans when I say that we need
more Lewis updates hmm i think we are
we're promised to get you know frequent
i'ma just update on what is up to you
yeah you know well Big Sam Lewis so uh I
don't know what what's going on with
Lewis you know i'm updating you as
frequently as there's news but
shockingly and this may not be a
surprise to people who sort of know
lewis's personality nothing has happened
since the last update so the last update
was Lewis has not yet moved to the south
Lewis has not yet gotten a job so and
that's still where things stand today I
know Lewis is very very much looking
forward to the super bowl in a couple of
days but I there's not much else Pat
that I can say you know and I don't know
if you're a member or not this collar
but he did call into the bonus show
about a month ago so that's a must see
yeah there's an entire bonus show which
if you're not a member you would have
missed we're all we did was getting a
very long update from Lewis while he was
in Florida checking out possible
relocation spots but things are moving
slow and there's been nothing since that
update that happened you know oh man I'm
gonna have to become a member them yeah
it's a dream on special it's a doozy but
me I will keep you apprised of any news
that actually happens in the world of
Lewis don't don't worry about that
that's my commitment yeah we we need
weekly oh good this update most weeks
would be nothing has changed that's the
problem that's where we're not getting
them weekly but we'll get them to you
alright thanks I really appreciate the
call always good to inquire about what's
going on with Lois it can be confusing
there's just no no update to give